The Joe Rogan experience.
So if you're gonna put someone on sort of a preventative protocol for mm-hmm
<affirmative> for COVID, you would recommend corset 10 and you can get it. We,
I just bought some on Amazon after you brought it up.
Cause I wasn't dating corset 10. Yeah. Um, course Atin at what dose?
Well, what we started off for, you know,
for daily use,
because the benefit of cosin is it drops the inflammatory cytokines. Um,
it increases mitochondria. So you produce more cells.
So you produce more energy ATP. That was what we were using for, for,
and it was 500 milligrams twice a day.
And zinc was 15 to 30 milligrams twice a day.
And in the past 20 years I've been sick 13 days.
And what I started seeing in our population,
because we do a monthly questionnaire to our patient population and we have two
questions about allergies and about, uh, infections or colds.
And we started seeing years ago that the number of colds people were having were
dropping and their allergies were improving. And honestly,
I didn't understand why until COVID and it started looking at how the
immune system is influenced by things like, uh,
zinc and certain of, uh, testosterone testosterone stimulates the,
um, CD four CD eight cells,
which are the immune cells that help to defend us against infections, viral,
bacterial, innate immunity, as well as it increases, uh,
something called Interlukin 10, which is an anti-inflammatory product.
And it drops the inflammatory, um, interleukins.
These are the cytokines or produced by our immune system to help fight off
infection by sending out an attack against them,
which is a biochemical attack other than just antibodies.
So you've got zinc 15 to 30 milligrams twice a day course.
At ten five hundred milligrams twice a day. That's preventive treatment.
And we've had to treat patients outside of our practice is a thousand milligrams
twice a day with 30 M a thousand milligrams,
twice a day of Corin and 30 milligrams twice a day of zinc.
And this is for someone that has COVID,
that's someone who's active and what is what's going on with zinc and Cotin,
and, and COVID like, how, how is, oh, how does it.
Interact? Yeah, well,
the virus that gets into our cells,
it gets ourselves through something called an ACE two receptor.
And that's what the, um, vaccine is fighting against.
They call it the spike protein.
So on the outer membrane of the virus of these spikes.
So it uses our own system to transport the virus into the
cell. Once it's in the cell, the virus releases something called replicate.
Replicates is a DNA reverse transcriptase protein that takes over
our manufacturing at the ribosome to make more viral genome. Well,
it turns out that the, uh,
replicates has an area on it that if zinc attaches to it shuts it off.
So Corin is called an IOF four.
It carries charge particles into the cell. Otherwise zinc sits outside the cell.
So zinc without a X Zif four. That is that a I four I four I O yeah.
Zi without an IO four. It just, it doesn work. Correct. Interesting.
So a lot of these people that are just taking zinc on its own doesn't.
Right. Doesn't go into the cell. Yeah. Generally speaking,
it won't get into the cell at a high rate.
It will over time get in because we have things that we take in like, uh,
BI myth in our system from fruits and vegetables. We have, uh,
E G C G from green tea. If people are drinking and green tea, um, we've got,
uh, curcumin from food. That's why in India, they don't get it.
So they're getting some form of an nine four,
but if you wanna really jam the zinc into the cells, um,
use of Corin or turmeric.
Or, and then move on to D three, um, I'm taking 5,000,
I use a day. What do you, what.
Do you recommend? I, I personally take a little bit more than that.
How much do you take 50,000 Jesus Christ on Mondays and 10 or
20,000 on every other day. That's a lot.
Why?
I don't know. Yeah, that's right. <laugh> most people I don't know.
But is there any negative aspect to, uh.
Yeah, there are negative aspects to high levels of vitamin D,
but not due to vitamin D due to what it does,
what vitamin D does. As I said earlier,
is it brings calcium in from your nutrition and takes phosphorus in.
So it can build bone calcium. If it's too high,
hyperemia will cause the, um,
nausea of vomiting and can cause irregularity of the heart.
So if you're taking high dosing of calcium, for whatever reason,
and you take high dosing of vitamin D,
you would be at risk for developing nausea, vomiting, and toxicity,
a study that was done, which is also on the paper I gave you.
They did 113,000 hospitalized people.
And they looked at their vitamin D level. They all had been taken vitamin D.
They only found,
I think it was four people who had toxicity from elevated levels of vitamin D
and it turned out it was the liquid form of vitamin D that created the problem.
So from that standpoint,
vitamin D is very safe and I'm talking up numbers that are 60 to a hundred.
I tried to keep my range at 80 to a hundred because of studies that are shown.
Do you take calcium?
No.
You don't. Why not? I,
I have to my nutrition and I monitor my calcium every six months of my blood
work. So if my levels are where they should be.
I'm fine. Okay.
So what do you look for in nutrition to get your calcium from what.
Are you getting it from? Um, you know, I eat cheese. I,
my daughter pulled me off of cows milk and tried me on, uh, goat, cheese,
goat cheese. She gives me all that stuff. So, um, in my cheese, I get it.
And then, you know, there are foods that I eat, I chew on bones,
so I get a little calcium that way that chew on bones.
No, I'm just kidding. But, um, cuz I take bone meal. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Allison makes a, a bone broth. Mm, okay. Yeah.
She makes bone broth at home. So it has good bone marrow, you know,
protein and uh, some calcium, I don't know how much calcium you get from it. It,
but uh, I monitor, I'm getting it someplace in my.
Nutrition. So for someone who has osteoporosis mm-hmm, <affirmative>, let's,
let's look point to them. They're uh, recommended to take calcium. Right?
Correct. Now they're taking calcium and they have vitamin D three. Correct.
Then they must be careful about what the levels of vitamin D three they take.
Correct.
And.
The, what do you recommend men to someone who's taking calcium? Like what,
what levels?
See I use the science. I use the laboratory to tell me how much, you know,
I get ridiculed by my colleagues because I'm giving everybody a baseline of
10,000 units and they say, oh, that's toxic.
It's gonna call pro you go and do the blood test. And you see giving 'em 10,000.
They get a, you know, still suboptimal level of,
of vitamin D it's because they're not absorbing it.
So I can't assume that 10,000 is gonna give them toxic levels, you know,
calcium absorption. So I, I start at, uh, five to 10,000,
10,000 seems to be the amount and then their calcium, they get, they have a, a,
a prescribed product which has calcium and vitamin D and a ad, uh,
uh, combination already.
So, um, who makes that, uh, I don't.
Remember which pharmaceutical, I don't use it. You don't use.
What was the issue with the liquid.
Vitamin D? Yeah. The only thing is with liquid vitamin D. Yeah.
But why you think? Uh, because the absorption rate,
because it gets absorbed so well, cap and encapsulated, you know, it's fat size,
you take it after meal that gets absorbed and based upon how good the gut is,
you know, dysbiosis, it will regulate how you absorb it.
So I don't assume anything.
I'll put a patient on a protocol and then three months later I'll go and test
them and see where their levels are at.
If they're at a great level on that amount, that's perfect for them.
How do I know that whatever I'm giving them is gonna be too, too much,
too little or.
Perfect. And then the,
the level of absorption which will indicate in their blood will,
will indicate what, what,
what levels are shown in the blood is directly related to their diet as well.
Correct. And, and the other nutrients they're taking, it's related.
To the status of their gut, the lining of their gut.
It's relative to, if they took it before food or during food, with food,
it's a fat soluble, fat soluble vitamins, like, uh,
vitamin E um, vitamin D or hormone, uh,
D uh, or D H E a, they all need, um,
food to optimize the absorption.
Okay. So, so we got D three mm-hmm <affirmative>, uh,
which you take at very high. Well, but what do you recommend? 10,000.
Uh.
You need to have a blood test. Okay.
Before we put anybody on vitamin D we don't just abstractly, you know,
put 'em on a number, right. We check their levels.
And I've been absolutely amazed at not only the frequency of deficiency
of vitamin D,
but the fact that I've got surfers who have deficiency of vitamin D how can you
be a surfer out there in the sun and be vitamin D deficient wetsuits,
right? Well, they wear maybe the top,
but their arms and legs below the belly is exposed.
Four hours. I'm I'd see a lot of guys with full wetsuits out there.
Cause that Pacific ocean it's cold. It gets cold. It's.
Cold. Yeah. But when they get out, they lay down on the beach, you know,
they get, I.
Think, I think human beings need a lot of sun. Uh.
I think that genetics are changing. Yeah. Are they? Yeah, I think so. Look it.
Why did we develop this whole system of vitamin D the vitamin receptor
stimulates hair growth to cover our body with hair,
to avoid the ionizing radiation that our ancestors neolithic ancestors used
to have, they were getting cancer.
They were getting exposed to high levels because the air was clear.
There was no smog back then.
So they were getting full strength of the radiation from the sun and they were
dying. So.
The, you saying it smogs protecting us from cancer. Uh,
is that what you're saying? Bingo. Relative.
Relative to son <laugh> joke.
Just piece it all together. Yeah. So brilliant. Hong Kong, like not Hong Kong,
like, uh, what, what are the Chinese cities? Beijing, Beijing,
Beijing really bad.
I was there.
Yeah. I used to work there. That's right.
They did Olympics there and they said it was like the worst air quality we've
ever had for the Olympics.
And the only way they got the air clear,
there was shutting down all the manufacturing that's in the,
one of the inner circles.
See Beijing grew so rapidly that they have 10 rings around it.
And I think in the fourth or fifth ring is where they have all the
manufacturing. So when the financial summit happened, they shut 'em all down.
Air was clear, absolutely clear. And the silliest thing,
I was there for new year's one year in February, and they shot off
$45 million worth of, um,
rockets and fireworks and firecrackers and all that added pollution.
You couldn't breathe. And I was on the 27th floor of a building.
Couldn't breathe up there. Really? Yeah. It was pretty bad. Pretty.
Bad. So, okay. So, um, D three. Yes, we, so we got Corin,
we got, uh, zinc, zinc, 30 milligrams twice a day. Um,
or that's the, that's a therapeutic therapeutic.
A thousand milligrams twice a day with 30 twice a day of.
Sync. Um, then D three figure out what the levels are,
but what you're taking is somewhere.
I, I I'm taking, uh, what about, uh, 120,000 a.
Week? If someone doesn't have like a good place to go, they don't,
they don't have a good doctor to go.
How do they find a doctor that could read their vitamin levels on,
on the blood work? Like what, what do you look for? Like,
if someone's listening to this, like I should get my blood work done. Who,
who do they go to? Right.
Well, functional medicine is big now. And in functional medicine,
they're looking at your amino acids. They're looking at your vitamin levels.
They're looking at your mineral levels, which need to be done.
We're not getting our minerals anymore because we're getting bottled water.
How many minerals are in here? Zero.
All of them.
All right.
Zero is, well, that's hard water, right? Like, well, water.
That's what people call for the mountains. Hard water.
We're not for the mountains. I know. But, but that's what hard water is, right.
When you get's.
Calcium hydroxide or calcium oxide, whatever it.
Is, calcium, it's some minerals in the water, right? Yeah. And.
Uh,
you can buy the minerals and put a couple of drops into the bottle and I take.
Coital colo. That's it. That's it. Um, so you got your D three,
you got your cosin, you got your zinc. Uh, what about vitamin C? Uh, vitamin.
C helps with immune system. 'em um, how much do you take? I don't take,
uh, vitamin C really?
No. What.
Do you take?
I have two or three pieces of citrus fruit that I grow in my backyard, um,
every morning, every now and then, uh, Allison will bring in some of the, uh,
from here it's called strawberry, Texas, uh,
grape for it's phenomenal, sweet as can be a strawberry grapefruit. They,
they call it strawberry because of the color. The usual one is the, um,
pink grapefruits from Texas mm-hmm <affirmative> and not the yellow ones from
Florida, but the pink ones. And they're very high in vitamin C.
Also I grow com QUTs so I'll eat the whole thing.
So they have a lot of natural com QUTs and I get two a year, so I'm always with,
uh, natural forms, so. Okay. So you just get it most, I get it all naturally.
Yeah. What.
Other, uh, I mean, this is all we're talking about,
like during this COVID COVID right.
Pandemic where everybody's really concerned about their immune system and
protecting themselves from yeah.
D H E is also an immune stimulator,
D H E of studies that came outta Massachusetts, uh, male aging study,
um, showed that D H E is extremely important for protecting the heart. Um,
when they looked at, you know,
Cortile's the lowest 25% of the range versus the highest you saw a significant,
uh, loss of heart attack deaths and a significant decrease in hospitalization
due to heart attack. And that's D H E it also stimulates the immune system.
So it upregulates the ability of our system to defend itself.
So it's a higher quality of, uh, defense and another issue with vitamin D.
I mean, with, uh,
D H E is D H E is important for allowing D
HT DIH testosterone into the cell. And why is that important?
DHT is a byproduct at testosterone because it's the combination of D H E
getting DHT dihydrate testosterone in the cell that allows for sugar to be
brought into the myocytes, into the muscle cells.
So there are articles out there talking about,
if you want to get the optimal benefit for muscle growth,
you need to make sure your D H E levels are optimal to get the D HT to
increase glycogen in the muscle cells. So use that for energy and for growth.
Catch new episodes that Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog JRE videos on Spotify, including clips,
easily seamlessly switch between video and audio experience
on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.